what's up you guys movie retrospective
time
so the movie that won the poll this week
pretty overwhelmingly was a tim burton
flick
the
1999 sleepy hollow
pretty good flick yeah i mean it's not
his best one but i kind of feel like
it's one that
i don't know if i'd say like a lot of
people don't talk about it but i
remember seeing this when it came out in
the theater back in 1999 and i remember
really liking it like it looks fantastic
but being like
i didn't love it
but i think i've developed like more of
an appreciation for it like as i've
watched it more times you know what i
mean tim burton is just too tim burton-y
and this one isn't very tim burton-y i
mean it it has a lot of his little
tropes in it
but it's not
it's not you know it's not going over
the top i mean his wife said it like
always and just you know some of the
same people but yeah it's just how he
does it you know and a lot of directors
do that to be fair i mean i know he does
get picked on because he puts johnny
depp in everything but
like i said a lot of degree yeah like a
lot of directors like have actors that
they particularly like to work with i
think maybe the reason that this this
isn't tim burton in the way that
in in the kind of like insulting way
that you say that yeah um is because
this initially wasn't really his idea so
this wasn't a movie that he developed
from the outset you know what i'm saying
the guy that developed this was actually
kevin yeager
who is a special effects guy
and he was actually the director on
tales from the crypt the hbo series
and he had an idea back in the early 90s
that he wanted to do an adaptation
of the legend of sleepy hollow the story
by washington irving
but he wanted to make it like a low
budget
slasher he's he calls it like a
pretentious slasher with like some big
like spectacular kill like every five
minutes
and so he was gonna do that he got like
the guy that wrote the screenplay for
seven and they kind of work together on
it
but he pitched it to the studio and they
were like well we like the idea of doing
the sleepy hollow thing but they didn't
really get we don't want to make it into
a slasher movie he's like they kind of
wanted to make it like a period piece
like the crucible or something like that
so he's like they didn't really get you
know exactly what his vision was for it
like a low budget thing so they wanted
to go more like a prestige
uh more independent kind of thing
so that's when tim burton got brought in
like in 1998 so it wasn't i mean tim
burton was really into the sleepy hollow
story and he even says that when he was
still in college one of his um
teachers
was
one of the animators that had worked on
the disney sleepy holly remember that
one like the ichabod crane which which
probably is the most uh faithful like
you know i really really like the disney
one yeah i really like the disney one so
but the thing about that so he really
likes like the headless horseman
character
but
he wanted to make this and this was kind
of like the his first kind of straight
up horror movie really which he he said
he thought that that was weird because
like horror was his favorite genre and
this was kind of like the first horror
movie that he made
but it's kind of like um the thing about
it is that he
the way it came out it's really not
much of anything like the short story
i mean you know
i could never i remember a bit of the
disney one that i grew up with i haven't
seen that [ __ ] a long time this is
nothing like that for what i remember
nothing not really there's like a little
bit in the scenes where they're like
homaging yeah but the thing about it is
that tim burton wanted to make this more
as
not like a slavish adaptation which i'm
not i guess you could make like a a
feature length it's a pretty short story
and
yeah you know what happens in it by
today's standards i mean yeah like not a
lot happens in it but it's you know so i
can see like wanting to make it into a
horror movie but he also wanted to
specifically make this
as sort of like an homage to hammer
films so he wanted to
yeah and i kind of feel like maybe in
1999
i think a lot of people didn't really
get that that's what he was going for
you know what i mean although this got
like it made a lot of money it made like
200 million something dollars and like a
lot of the critics most of the critics
seem to like they say oh you know it's
not his best one but it's like still
pretty good like it's you know looks
cool and everything but i think a lot of
people back then
didn't get that he was homaging
hammer films you know what i mean and
it's if you watch it again in that light
it seems like super obvious
but he was also homaging stuff like
black sunday like the mario baba movie
like um he said one of the influence too
was like scream blacula scream uh jason
and the argonauts like he wanted so he
kind of wanted this sort of like
expressionist
again like a hammer kind of look to it
having all kind of all these uh you know
sort of dignified like british actors
like in all these roles and kind of hot
he's in it yeah and and also having like
this sort of scientific based character
uh you know kind of chasing the monster
yeah so i ca you know in that light it
really does kind of work and it does
even have like some dark humor in it if
you notice too and i actually didn't
notice this until i just watched it
again last night was that he even goes
backwards and makes the blood
look like bright red blood like in the
hammer movies like instead of like
realistic blood which i was like oh yeah
i i guess i didn't even really notice
that johnny depp's working it he i think
i thought he did pretty good at that at
this character at ichabod yeah and him
set up as a police investigator that was
quite a different twist because
originally that's not what it was yeah
he was a school teacher in the original
story now i will say that johnny depp
his original idea when they said okay
well you want to play ichabod crane even
though they the studio said to tim
burton well we know that you want johnny
depp because we know that's how you do
but they're like well how about uh brad
pitt or how about liam neeson or he's
like yeah those are nice but yeah we're
doing it christopher walken plays the
headless horseman he does yeah he they
give a little bit of backstory him being
a hesh and mercenary working which
that's from the short story yeah and
working for the british
uh to keeping the american
colonialists under the [ __ ] yoke of
the [ __ ] empire and he was just
bloodthirsty and he eventually got
betrayed and killed by his own sword and
his head was lost and he's looking for
it kind of deal and he's getting
vengeance on people but then it comes
turns out that the witch has brought him
back and this one yeah it's kind of i
think it's a better kind of a
better twist that he was brought back
for a reason and then the way it ends
pretty good too kind of a happy ending
for the headless horseman
i yeah i guess so gets him a bride well
i mean to be fair she had sold her soul
to satan when she was a kid so he just
came to cash that cash that in yeah he
finally gets her get gets his hands on
the witch
yeah
because she is fine go back to hell
with this
yeah like miranda richardson who plays
the stepmom in this one uh she's pretty
great and like i said she's very over
the top but that's kind of like what
that's the tone that he was going for
and i swear to god that dress that she
wears like that white one with all that
black
uh kind of like embroidery or whatever
the hell it is over it is amazing yeah i
would totally wear the [ __ ] out of that
but yeah so
in the in the original short story the
the guy like the headless horseman he
was a hessian mercenary but i think his
head got blown off by a cannonball
if i remember correctly i mean i just re
i just read it like a year or two ago or
something like that so yeah i think his
head got blown off by a cannonball
and then he was just like but see in the
short story
it's pretty strongly implied
that the headless horseman doesn't
really exist that it's just a story they
don't come out and say that but
when you know ichabod crane gets chased
by the headless horseman and the
headless horseman throws the
throws the head at him and then they
don't see ichabod crane again
you're kind of it's implied that brom
bones the guy that was kind of like
vying with ichabod crane for katrina van
tassel's affections had dressed up like
the headless horseman and thrown a
pumpkin at his head like to get rid of
like to scare the [ __ ] out of him and
get him out of town
now i thought so i thought it was
interesting that
i don't know like this movie almost like
thematically completely inverts the
point of the original story in the
original story ichabod crane was kind of
a douche
um he's not i don't know if i'd call him
the villain that's i guess he is kind of
the villain but he comes into the town
and he's you know kind of a kind of a
[ __ ] and then like everybody in town
is like kind of trying to run him out
because he's so annoying you know what i
mean so he's almost kind of like the
villain whereas in this one he's like
the hero he comes into the town and
you know saves them from the thing from
what i remember what i remember the
original one i haven't seen in a long
time he was just kind of a like you said
he's kind of a douche yeah and um that
was not
uh he and he didn't fit in and during
the time yeah during the time that story
was written that was not a virtue to be
different exactly yeah that's what i'm
saying yeah so
you know nowadays you got kids saying
well i'm autistic that kind of and
that's kind of the way damn ichabod is
kind of
portrayed based nowadays you say he was
like he he had autism or something you
know and then well i don't know if i'd
go that far but he was kind yeah he was
kind of a goofball or kind of a quad
well that's like he didn't really have
like a lot of uh social great and also
he was very wesley my cousin wesley has
real autism all right
and that [ __ ] is goofy and
socially unacceptable and we'll do all
kinds of [ __ ] and so that i so i'm
correct when i say kind of like autism
well the thing about it was kind of like
you know you know a puppy that won't
stop jumping up and down and hey hey oh
no he was like that and when that was
written at a time
in a society where being that way they
discourage people from being that way
that's not what that's not what society
wanted so the the story from i remember
correctly kind of pointed out that
he was a he was a goofy son of some
[ __ ] and and and had a swordsman got
him i think that's how it did it didn't
didn't the horseman get him
no i said that it's pretty strongly
implied that
the that brom bones dressed up like the
headless horseman
and scared him so he ran out of town in
the original one yeah so they ran them
out of town but what i the thing about
the thing that makes ichabod crane a
villain in the story is not so much that
he's a goofball it's that he's um kind
of like social climbing he's like really
grasping and selfish like he goes to the
parties
and you know he eats all their food and
then he's like he's trying to like
better his status by like kind of using
people like on his way up so i think
that it's more he's more like kind of i
don't know if i'd go so far as to say
manipulative but
he does have a little bit of that where
he's always trying to like make his
status better you know what i mean so
it's also kind of implied and
as as far as i remember like because
like i said i read it about a year ago
that he doesn't really
i mean maybe he has feelings for katrina
but he may he mostly wants to marry her
because her dad is rich
like because he wants to so he's kind of
like that kind of [ __ ] that's
kind of how they were back then though
yeah i mean but but they're i mean the
whole point of the story the original
short story was that he was kind of the
bad guy yeah and like the townsfolk were
kind of like right to like run him out
of town yeah like using the legend well
you ran freaks out of town beckons
that's what i'm saying
so interestingly this movie which you
know very much in line with tim burton's
other stuff because he's very much a
champion of the outsider yeah um you
know and culturally things are very
different nowadays than they were back
when the story was written in 1820
but
so you have ichabod crane who
is a little bit less he's a little bit
dorky but he's not like
super dorky i will note that johnny depp
actually wanted to do the full-on
ichabod crane experience like how he
looks like how he looks in the short
story like with his big old jug ears and
those big like creepy long fingers and
that big like long nose and he's like
all like arms legs and elbows and stuff
like like he's drawn in the disney
cartoon he wanted to do something like
that and i'm like gangly kind of i'm
like i i'm glad they didn't do that
because that would have just been i
think that would have been a step too
far you know what i'm saying especially
since they changed the character so much
he still has the sort of like nervous
cowardly
kind of [ __ ] but he does actually like
sack up and like do some [ __ ] in the
original story they point out that uh
one one time's pretty famous
quote in that movie that um because
ichabod crane was a young single man and
wasn't in anybody's debt nobody cared
about him he could disappear and people
like i will [ __ ] it
well that's what they did at the end
because they never found him but they
were like oh well glad he's gone yep it
was pretty much more or less it was kind
of like it was kind of whether the
headless horseman got him or brom bones
got it right it was one of the other
1820s but they were still they were
still like on um the damn folklore level
of [ __ ] uh uh grimm's fairy tales
where uh
you you reach what you sow if you uh did
something wrong you got killed you were
a little kid and you you talked with
them people underneath the bridge they
ate it you know it's just like that if
you're a goofy sun [ __ ] and you're
young and you know nobody knows you you
they'll get rid of you that's what i
think that's what the what the more what
the moral that story was yeah don't be
an outsider fit in that's what the moral
yeah exactly story was exactly so like i
said the movie version is like the
complete opposite because in the movie
version
uh you know johnny depp playing ichabod
crane he's not a schoolteacher in this
he's actually a police constable
and he's sent from the big city like new
york city and
he's kind of like at odds with uh the
authorities even where he's from because
they're still kind of like barbaric and
you know backwards and stuff and he's
trying to like bring in science and
progress and they just don't want to
[ __ ] hear it
so they get like really annoyed with him
always being like yeah but she you know
he's supposed to be like this champion
of like forensic science and reason and
everything and like i said they are just
kind of an impossible they're not having
it he's kind of an imposter when you
think about it though
because a lot of the stuff that he does
he's actually real grossed out by what
he's doing he does notice some stuff but
it looks kind of like some of the tools
that he had custom made
i don't know if they actually worked do
you think they actually were they
actually work well as i said that ending
that seemed to me that that was another
thing that was harkening back to like
the hammer films it's like it didn't
really matter whether they worked i mean
he did solve the mystery in the end
but
i think that depp was playing him
you know yeah he was a police constable
and he'd probably seen some [ __ ]
but
i feel like when he came out like he had
never seen anything like all these
people being beheaded and he'd never
maybe had to get like up close and
personal with the [ __ ] so he was like a
green horn so yeah so he was kind of
portraying him as like a little bit
timid in that sense
but he did get the job done way i was
interpreting it was is that he was
intelligent but he was kind of faking it
that he was
he was real new to it and he was trying
to
trying to be more than what he really
was in front of the other people who
were watching him so
i kind of felt that he slightly had a
little bit of an imposter
phenomenon going on with him where
he was kind of faking i i well i think
he was trying to impress everybody right
right like i think he did know what he
was doing like he was obviously
intelligent um yeah he was kind of like
goofy and had like some weird methods
and stuff but he said some [ __ ] though
that it didn't really add up remember he
said that that bought that head had been
cut off by a sword then and the sword
had cauterized the wound as if it was
flaming
i didn't see it flaming that that i
didn't see the headless horseman use any
flaming sword well it what no he didn't
say it was flaming he just said as
though the blade was like really hot
like as hot as fire and then like at
which point um i think the reverend or
something like that said oh like the
devil's blade or the blade from hell or
something like that so it wasn't
supposed to be like a fiery because that
was the thing like when he gets uh
stabbed by the by the um by the horsemen
like later yeah in the shoulder did it
cauterize it caught around okay so he
did detect it right okay yeah yeah it
did cauterize but there's kind of like
you'll see what you'll see in some of
the scenes he he has this kind of air
about himself like he's uh not real
secure in what he's doing and he's
trying and he's hiding the fact that
he's getting ready to throw up and how
about things and it it just
grows
well the thing about it is that he's
coming into this small town because like
i said in new york city like christopher
lee gets mad at him and yeah because
christopher lee has a cameo in this
which is great but they send him they're
like hey why don't you go off to this
like tiny little town in upstate new
york on sleepy hollow they bet they've
had all these like really exciting like
beheadings up there why don't you go try
your methods out like in some small town
yeah and see if it all works out because
we're kind of like sick of all your
scientific [ __ ] yeah because he had
all the scientific forensic [ __ ]
they didn't want to hear it and they
didn't want to hear anyone they're like
no we just want to beat people up for
confessions and then throw them in the
distance
so i guess he was legit he was legit
yeah yeah yeah they just didn't want to
hear what he had to say like the whole
theme of the movie is that and the
reason that maybe he was acting like
that when he came to sleepy hollow was
because he probably saw himself as like
the agent of change the agent of
progress he's bringing science to this
backward little town and so he was
trying to like put on like an air of
authority which maybe he didn't really
feel that obviously because this was the
first time he'd done that but but i so i
think it was like it was a good
portrayal in that way because you could
tell that maybe he thought oh you know i
i don't really know he knew what he was
doing but
he was rewatchable it is it is i mean
it's really really um i mean the best
thing about it i think is the visuals it
is
beautiful it is a beautiful beautiful
movie to look at the costumes it
actually uh i think it won an oscar for
art direction if i'm not mistaken and i
think it got nominated for costume
design as well although it didn't i
immediately um saw the hammer influence
in it but i'll tell you one thing though
not as boobalicious as hammers that's
true
i mean there were some boobs but there
was some but i was going like because
the the the period costumes that they're
using are basically damn push-up what do
you call the damn things bustiers and
stuff and well of course and corsets and
uh i was
i knew christina ricci was in it and i
was going like man we're gonna get
they're gonna break it off for christina
ricci here they're gonna see her in that
bustier it didn't it didn't happen
didn't happen although some of the
witches i think kind of had a little a
little bit more like a hammer girl see
because hammer horror if you guys never
watch a hammer horror movie
that was just uh
it was it was it was a way of showcasing
gorgeous european boobs it was
yes
and they were good actresses too now all
right it's not like they would it's not
like la where they just get some [ __ ]
porn star bibb or something to dress her
up they were real actresses but they
they were hotties
and then you'd have christopher [ __ ]
christopher reeves in that and
christopher reeves
[Laughter]
you have christopher lee in it and you'd
have you know a dude that played grand
moff tarkin in it you know what's his
name um theater cushion peter gushing
i'm drawing a blank on all those british
guys but they'd be in it classing up the
[ __ ] joint hammer hammer made good
good flicks
they're fun 60s stuff you know
yeah and i mean yeah yeah you can
definitely tell like that see where he's
coming from that tim burton was was into
that and like i said you can see like
it's because kind of looks like black
sunday too yeah but the thing about it
was burton initially him and the
cinematographer they wanted to shoot
this in black and white yeah uh and they
actually wanted to shoot it in the
square like the what they call the
academy ratio um but the you know
paramount i think it was who made this
and they were like absolutely not right
so what they decided to do instead was
well they're like well if you can't film
it in black and white we're just gonna
like drain
most of the [ __ ] of color and then have
that bright bright blood so it looks
like so that's pretty much what they did
like they made everything just like
really dark and shadowy and i kind of
feel like this is this is one of the
best movies to watch like right around
halloween this is a really good
halloween yeah
season it's a visual movie yeah yeah
and you know what's interesting too and
i didn't realize this
initially they wanted to shoot this on
locations they wanted to shoot it
actually in upstate new york where the
original story took place so they went
to terrytown and they were going to
shoot it there but they couldn't get it
quite right blah blah blah and so in the
end they had to shoot it or they they
ended up shooting it on it's all shot on
sound stages
in english yeah what i liked about it is
that the visuals were good they were
mostly realistic uh they were kinda
pretty much period actually
um a high-end period
and uh you didn't have all that weird
nightmare before christmas and gothic
style tim burton [ __ ] stretched
[ __ ]
only a couple times did tim burton
homage tim burton and that was like when
you know he would show a scarecrow or
something you'd definitely like
something that tim burton came up with
yeah really like that scarecrow yeah but
the buildings in the architecture and
the forest look like real places so i
liked that yeah i liked that part you
know and um
the i really liked the costumes the um
the weapons that guys were using uh when
the hessian uses uh weapons you see him
with his head on too
oh [ __ ] with uh christopher walken he
looks good his hair's all ratted out and
his teeth are all filed down and he
looks all [ __ ] crazy and [ __ ] yeah
you they're just using like a straight
long broad sword or uh
or uh francis which are battle axes he
had those um
or tom
in america later on they called
tomahawks we'd sell them to the indians
indians who love those things too then
they'd make their own but that was a
french weapon brought here during the
french and indian wars and even before
that was used a lot
um
francis
somebody might call it a francaise
that's a [ __ ] french battle axe real
light look not the big [ __ ] hokey
[ __ ] had a little blade on it like a
tomahawk you could swing it fast it was
on a wooden pole about that big matter
of fact i think i think i think gibson
uses one in that movie the patriot
during the revolutionary war dudes did
use those
they were good
better than a sword
if you know how to use it so uh there
was a lot of good combat with that we uh
i even saw they had a wheel lock in one
in one episode one
in one little uh scene they were on top
of a damn stagecoach and um
uh uh giant depp grabs a wheel lock
which a lot of people don't know what
that is and he uses he hits it
blows shoots the [ __ ] headless
horseman with it
normally in the muzzleloading rifle it's
it's a flintlock it's got a hammer that
comes down to flint a frison a flashpan
boom but there was a more expensive one
there was a wheel
that was
it was lit by a wheel that you cranked
up and when you hit the trigger the
wheel spun forward and it was like the
top of a zippo lighter or a big lighter
and make sparks and it go
like that you'd get positive ignition
and that was a [ __ ] high-speed weapon
back in the
1600s i think the 1500s might have not
they were 16 and 1700s
but uh i i was when i saw them
it they always throw in flintlocks but
when they included that wheel lock i was
impressed that they knew what that was
so yeah somebody did their reason
somebody did their research you know
what i'm saying yeah did you know too
that when um
when the headless horseman is walking
around son's head
uh that's actually not christopher
walken that's actually the dude that
played darth maul okay he's the same guy
like the stunt man yeah so yeah you can
see i really like like the way he spins
that [ __ ] yeah and dude so many
people get beheaded in this so many it
was i had forgotten i mean i remember
seeing this theater like i said being
like wow um this is definitely like a
horror movie
i think i was watching another review
and i think 14 there are 14 beheadings
in this movie uh including a little kid
a little kid gets beheaded after seeing
his mom get beheaded and her mom
the mom's head like rolls off and like
looks at him through the through the
basement slats or whatever and i was
just like man that's [ __ ] dark oh and
brom bones gets completely sliced in
half like
and there's like [ __ ] blood
everywhere and now they did use some
digital effects on this but i think
after what happened after mars attacks
tim burton was kind of like i kind of
wanted to go like as little digital
effects as possible so obviously the
headless horseman kind of stuff they had
you know the stuntman with the uh you
know blue
thing over his head or the green thing
over his head so they could rub it out
digitally but
they did like mostly practical effects
in this and honestly it looks pretty
[ __ ] great like all the heads and
[ __ ] like that all the beheadings are
like really gruesome and i've really
liked that about it um i will say that i
kind of feel like
the story is a little bit convoluted
but that's okay it doesn't really bother
me all that much because it's set up
more like a mystery like because he's a
detective and he comes there and then he
figures out well all these people that
are getting beheaded like something must
link all of them and so it's kind of
like this thing where he has to figure
out what the [ __ ] going on and
i like too that he comes in and he's
like this champion of science and
everything like that but when presented
uh evidence with his uh you know by his
own eyes that the supernatural headless
horseman exists he accepts it he's like
well i saw it so i guess it must exist
yeah and actually that's my favorite
scene like after he first sees it and he
like is wigging out as you would
um and he's like in the bed going the
headless horse it was headless i saw it
and like the guy from you know the the
guys in the town were like we know we we
all told you that's what it was and it's
like so i just think that's so funny
like their [ __ ] tone of that but like
i said he he freaks out but then he
comes out he's like okay well
you know i've i've i'm done with my
freakout obviously this is supernatural
and it exists so i accept that so now we
have to like figure out how to defeat it
or what the hell is going on with all
this so they do kind of set it up i have
seen some reviewers like compare this
almost in structure at least to not only
like a hammer movie but also like a
giallo movie because it's kind of like a
whodunit which i guess like maybe a
little bit
uh yeah it's more like a gothic measure
like i said a detective like a sherlock
holmes type yeah type mystery i kind of
feel it more like a sherlock holmes yeah
a little too coherent to be italian
yeah well no they're talking giallo in
the sense of it being like a murder
mystery where people get picked off one
by one and there's like something that
links all the way but they didn't invent
that it's like that no i know i'm just
saying it's more like a gothic
he was investiga by black sunday but
that's not a geolo that's a witch movie
yeah and this is a witch movie too
because that's what it turns out that
yeah the headless horseman yes he's
supernatural but he's being controlled
by a witch who stole his skull yeah sold
her soul to satan and she's like bumping
off people like to
get like some land and get revenge satan
gets his dude too because that's what i
mean yeah the swordsman gets his head
back and once he's got his head back
he's like oh well
now the witch that brought me here so i
can fair game so she goes he goes after
her well yeah she's up on her horse and
[ __ ] [ __ ] she's fine she sold her
soul and he's looking at it going oh
hell yeah
and he even kisses her blood starts
running out because he's got them damn
shark teeth and he jumped he got her on
the back of the horse and he jumps up
and they go into the damn tree into the
tree of death her hand was sticking out
of the limbs so i guess it killed her
but her soul went with him to
yeah well like i said she says later on
like in her long exposition scene where
she explains like why she summoned the
horsemen yeah um is that when she was a
little girl like in the flashback
earlier you realize that little girl you
saw on the flashback was heard
that she saw the hessian get killed
and she at that moment decided she was
going to sell her soul to satan and then
there was like this whole thing that
happened and then like that little girl
broke stick yeah okay yeah yeah that was
her all right yeah that was her so and
then the other little girl she got him
killed she broke the stick to the
[ __ ] authorities and they the
americans got him yeah and then the
other little girl was her sister who was
like the scary witch in the cave that
ichabod crane goes to like for
information you know what i mean she
ended up killing her too so i do you
know what i do like when christopher
walken when the headless horseman i do
like when he gets his head back like his
skull back and he kind of sticks it on
there and then like all the stuff starts
coming out and then
he just couldn't he couldn't resist he
had to get to he had to have a large
marge moment yeah where
the eyeballs pop out and the tongue pops
out a little bit yeah
tim burton he got tim brittany there for
a second but that's okay it looked like
somebody mars attacks like i said it
well it looked like a large merge from
peewee's big event
it was what it
you don't remember that scene that's
like that's the scene that everybody
remembers from that movie where large
marge the trucker she tells him the
scary story and then she turns and she
says you know it was a night just like
this and her face looked just like this
and turns her into her face because all
like eyeball popping out and stuff like
that so it kind of looks like that but
that's okay that's like a little bit of
self-homage i guess yeah um and i think
they're homaging tim bird yeah well you
know yeah he's he's that's what it feels
like whatever
whenever he does it's like he's so much
i kind of feel like a lot of people
think that
i don't know maybe we said this when we
were talking about mars attacks
but
i kind of feel like a lot of people
think that you know right around the
late 90s was right when he started like
losing
like right when he kind of started going
into maybe self-parody yeah um which i
guess he did he still made some good
movies there he made like big eyes which
was good and like [ __ ] like that but
i do kind of feel like at that point
like if every movie past that was kind
of like a greatest hits like like i saw
alice in wonderland and i didn't love it
like visually it was cool looking but i
didn't really like it as a movie yeah
willy wonka came out and then that was
effective i was like that was terrible i
really didn't like that at all
um
i mean he did make some good [ __ ] in
there but i do kind of feel like so i
feel like maybe this one
was even though
fans seem kind of divided on this um
most of them say yeah it looks beautiful
and stuff but some people think that
like the plot's too convoluted or you
know it should have been closer to the
you know short story or something um but
i still think this is like a really good
movie especially to watch around
halloween time because it really has
that vibe to it but i will admit that
probably after this one i think although
when did sweeney todd come out because i
liked someone like that one that was a
good one yeah that was that before this
one or after this one
hmm after was it after after when was it
four six when 2001
todd might swing i saw that in the
theater too but i can't remember what
yeah that was a lot later than that
maybe it was i thought that was like i
thought that was more like 2006
it might have been yeah i mean i think i
think we reviewed that but i can't
remember what year it came out so that
was still a good one yeah i mean it's
not his material well this isn't his
material either and like i said he
didn't originally develop this idea the
whole idea of ichabod crane being a
detective from new york city and coming
there to solve the beheadings that
wasn't tim burton's idea that was kevin
yeager's idea like he was the guy that
first developed it like the you know the
tales from the crypt guy so tim burton
is like not working on his own i kind of
feel like maybe tim burton's stuff other
than batman maybe i think his stuff is
usually better when it's his own
idea like beetlejuice you know what i
mean because that was like that was him
like all the way through like edward
scissorhands i think it's better if he
can just like design the whole thing
from the ground up like when he's
doing other people's stuff like other
people's ideas or he's adapting like
someone else's novel or something like
that it's still good but it's not quite
the same because he doesn't have it
seems like he doesn't have like quite
the same
passion for it or yeah well the thing
was is that that was
the tim burton thing the motif and
everything the vibe where he's coming
from
it's the late 80s goth yeah you know an
american late 80s guy yeah
and a lot of the younger audience have
no idea what the
no idea what the [ __ ] he's talking about
there's kind of like a big uh big
cultural
gap especially between normies you know
uh
so from here on out he's gonna be very
niche if he unless he does something
that's
like you said something that's really
unique but it has to
i don't know i'm not sure tim burton
type stuff would work
anymore am i
yeah i mean it seems like only people go
see the [ __ ] superhero movies [ __ ]
which are [ __ ] terrible half of them
most of them are terrible
um
i don't know jen i don't know about
[ __ ] tim burton anymore
well i like i said i haven't seen he
would make movies that me and you would
like but i don't know if [ __ ] that
would sell yeah you know well like i
said this one made a lot of money so i
mean this is back in the night yeah i
don't know about now yeah i mean he's
older now so it's just so it's kind of
like a difference
if it's a time different vibe he said
he's in a different place now and when
and when like when his movie like when
beetlejuice and stuff like that came out
that was like really out there and it
was like people were like wow check that
out now i kind of feel like everybody's
seen everything so you can do like not
what it is you can do like some
weird-ass [ __ ] and be like yeah that's
some weird ass [ __ ] but no one's gonna
yeah
it's like yeah i seen weirder you know
what i mean yeah
i think i think after what what's his
name said you know and that uh after the
after that dude you know [ __ ] after
chris rock got slapped so i can do that
dude came on he goes we're not the cool
kids anymore [ __ ] and that's really
kind of what it is hollywood studio the
big hollywood studios that's not the
cool kids anymore
all the cool kids now are [ __ ] making
their own material
yeah well like we said because it's a
lot easier it's a lot easier you know so
it's it's harder to stand out nowadays
yeah which is a blessing and a curse i
guess right but yeah i mean honestly
let us know what you think about sleepy
hollow because i feel like this is one
that you know a lot of people really
like it and then some people are just
like man you know what i mean but to me
this seems like a really good this is
like the perfect halloween movie like to
put on a halloween party or some [ __ ]
like that i don't really care that much
that it's not
all that faithful to the story i mean it
does have the little thing a little
scene with brom bones like dressed up
like the headless horseman to like
homage that but i kind of like that he
did his own [ __ ] with it i mean the
headless horseman looks great he's super
scary it's super gory there's lots of
beheadings and i'm into that so and it's
also kind of like darkly humorous as
well and it's got a great [ __ ] cast
and it looks amazing so
you know i'm i'm happy that's all i have
to say but yeah so that'll do it for
this movie retrospective we will see you
guys on the next one bye